those first few weeks of March had so
much happening at once the NBA was
cancelled stockpiling was happening
nationwide and grocers that couldn't
deal with the band and as all as the
Senate happening at once there's a
little note company called lineage
logistics which moves 30 percent of our
country's fresh and frozen food huge
deal for crisis like this and make sure
our meeting workers and the CEO started
working with Seth Curry and others in
the NBA to try to partner and to see if
they could have some of the you know
former NBA Stadium workers getting moved
over to lineages frozen warehouses and
and how they could vocalize and
redistribute some of the labor which was
furloughed or put out of work through
this crisis and to areas that you know
needed it if are more lending it's just
290 warehouses around the world some of
those are managed for Walmart others are
for Kroger so lineage started working
with the Curry's foundation because it
needed help moving millions of meals
students in Oakland who were hungry and
in need and weren't in school anymore
getting said so lineage donated some
pallet space and offered to move the
food for free to the food bank and work
with the foundation
we did not know lineage logistics you
know five weeks ago and funny enough it
was Stefan who called me and said you
know the Warriors GM Bob Myers I was
just on a call with him and he has this
company that that is interested in
healthy now you know can you hop on the
phone with them and and and see what
it's all about and see how we convince
we work together to help Oakland
families and so I did you know we had
never heard of lineage but quickly
learned that they were a powerhouse and
could be you know instrumental to our
efforts to get food to the kids and
families who need ammo
and so so that's how it started but you
know over the next week you had Stefan
on the phone with various leaders at
lineage logistics trying to figure out
the mechanisms of of working together
and so the vast majority of kids who go
to Oakland Public Schools are on free or
reduced school lunches and so you know
we do a lot of work providing direct
support to provide food to kids and
families and then we're also getting
involved in some of these important
policy discussions around making sure
that breakfast is a part of a public
school day of making sure that school
food our summer food programs are robust
and making sure kids are fed during the
summer which is a which is a scary time
for kids you know dealing with the issue
of hunger
this definition curry started their
foundation last year to really mobilize
for the hungry and young kids in Oakland
Ayesha actually was on her under 30 list
of years ago and has been doing a lot of
amazing work in hunger with food banks
for years and actually has her own show
so there was a lot of overlap especially
you know when you think about the right
people to be mobilizing an effort around
food and feeding that hungry in a time
like this we started having some of
these discussions about a week before
Oakland Unified School District closed
their schools indefinitely and we
realized that hunger was going to be a
huge issue and so we have a pre-existing
deep relationship with the incredible
food bank in our community Alameda
County Community Food Bank and so we we
partnered with them and and had been
mobilized you know really within an hour
of Oakland Unified School District
closing
through this crisis multiple izing food
and getting food to the right locations
India has been vastly important and
really challenging logistically its
players like lineage logistics that are
really responsible for getting the food
we need the places we need right now
without them there will be huge gaps in
our food system that could fall risk and
be threatened as this crisis continues